yo guys so we just
finished watching falcon and winter
soldier the first episode
cannot say anything specific about it i
mean i can at least tell you
it's easily the best falcon action
we've ever seen uh the tone is great the
pacing is really cool
feels more on par with something like uh
winter soldier
absolutely it's very character driven
there's some nice
exploration surprise you know i just
keep we obviously show our reaction
can't post it until the episode's out
it's hard not to go in but dude it's
pretty cool it's pretty cool stuff man
it's really cool in our reaction i
really like this definitely it's
100 different than something like one
division but damn is it um
yeah it's it's really great i can't wait
for you guys to see your reaction to it
uh
yeah it was really sucked in all right
bye oh yeah i also had
like the full-length watch alongside me
on patreon so you know if you want to
like pledge to us there if you want but
original keep looking for the reaction
highlights here oh my god
you